y'en a un qui a toutes les chances
d'être fun c'est ben ben vautier et sur
les nets bien au chaud sous la couette
caylar michaud alors benjamin vautier
alias ben
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
tu es arrivé à nice en 49 tu as été
d'abord libraires et après tu as été
brocanteurs et avait un magasin de
disques étaient très célèbre wii estime
exane du temps que je faisais des expos
et donc vous m'ont donné
et puis j'ai essayé de montrer ce qu'ils
avaient de nouveau dans le meck ce
magasin de disques un jour ils étaient
exposés à beaucoup à faire maintenant
est exposé à vous hisser font du ski a
trouvé que c'était une belle oeuvre et
que moi même aussi bassiste et d'un
magasin à nice dans lequel je t'ai rien
je connais tout au mieux parce qu'il y
avait eu marcel duchamp il ya eu le
nouveau réalisme et donc je voulais
telle une oeuvre d'art en du chan avait
dit tout et à et toi tu dis une fois
qu'il ya eu touchant tout et terry mais
heureusement tout est à jeudi que d'une
tâche de deschamps il nous amène dans
une situation
désespéré dans la mesure où deschamps
exposé importe où tu es donc tout est
possible
impossible de faire du land art du
coureur du pont pas du nouveau réalisme
tout est dans tout et perrier-jouët ses
pions là mais dans l'intérim d'avant
c'est à dire que c'est accepté d'avancer
tenir le choc mais manger tout cru que
en art qu'il fallait apporter quelque
chose
c'est à dire un avis qui veut le produit
est moins intéressant qu'un artiste qui
apporte donc il faut apporter quelque
chose
donc toute ma première partie ma période
ça a été l'un des deux apporté du
nouveau cirque donc j'ai cherché du
nouveau je m'étais dit personne a fait
des coups de pied au cul donc je veux
signer écoute et opu besson a signé le
manque donc je signe et le membre d'un
sauna fait ceci est donc ça c'est être
dans les années cinquante huit où j'ai
méthodiquement cherché à faire ce qui
n'avait pas été fait puisque je m'étais
dit l'histoire de la cecc une histoire
des choses qu'on fait pas donc un jour
tu t'es dit bon je sais pas klein il a
fait le bleu moi je vais faire les
textes par exemple ça c'était l'époque
c'était très simple et ex si tu veux
savoir un joueur m'a demandé d une
exposition de goût et je suis allé voir
sur les autres exposés et je me suis dit
ben moi je voudrais qu'on le garde mon
tableau danger qui le guette et moi s'il
vous plaît ne regardez pas les autres
alors ensuite ceci dit comme ça le
regarde et après je me suis dit je veux
dire la vérité parce que quand tu le
garant rembrandt ou quand tu regardes un
petit génie derrière laurent blanc si tu
grattes un peu il y a un ego ya un grand
blond qui regardaient mois-ci vous
feront blanc
regardez moi qu'on tirait le garder moi
moche qu'elle le garde est mort boys
donc tout une histoire de
l'assainissement des goûts de deux mois
qui crie a demandé regarder ce que j'ai
découvert de nouveaux des restes a été
par exemple c'est non mais dont je
m'intéressais à la vérité tu vois jeune
homme de vérité où j'essaie de la vérité
parce qu'il ya les prix c'est parti donc
avec et subjective je suis jaloux de
beuys je suis jaloux de boltanski je
l'écrivais sa voix l'ag qui laisse
apparaître en tant qu'artiste un échec
par exemple admettons
oui je voulais écrire parce qu'il ya une
angoisse j'écrivais mes angoisses ou un
homme j'écrivais les vérités objectives
qui sont par exemple sur une toile de 45
cm de long tu écris ces toiles et 15
centimètres de long beach et qui elle
est noire donc là il peut pas tuer le
contraire 1 ici ils peuvent pas dire
ouais mais les planches d'étudier les
noirs et c'est simple donc ramener les
choses à leur plus communs plus simple
dominateur commun comment dire l'école
tu vas tu écrivais par exemple je peins
pour la gloire
parce que c'était vrai ouais bien sûr
parce que c'était vrai mais maintenant
la gloire j'en suis devenu ce n'est pas
que j'aie la loi mijo j'ai un problème
de moi qui me gêne je n'écrirai plus
collaborative et pendant que vous
regardez le temps passe pas oui ça c'est
vrai c'est une vérité subjective au
début des années 60 soit était de
participer à la création du mouvement
fluxus avec nam zhu pets qu'on a reçus
avec les hauts fourneaux avec john tate
bien sûr pensé quoi fluxus parce qu'on
l'a dit fluxus en plus que ses dadas
plus du vaudeville
c'est vrai ça c'est tu connais un peu
cheap act up et ça c'est fluxus tu vois
du champ il prend le poste bouquet oui
mais dans une exposition d'un est le
signe que je suspends le port bouteille
le maire aka bois et mais les bouteilles
dessus la différence entre fluxys et
deschamps sait que le cursus essaie de
faire joindre la vie dans l'art mais
l'algérie c'est un échec parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à se libérer de leur écot
ouais donc ils sont toujours là avec
leur ego et quand john kane ch'tis tout
est musique c'est pas vrai du tout et
john cage réalité économique ou quand
les gens plus bien sûr sur scène et
boire un verre d'eau ils essaient de
nous faire croire que la vie est à mais
c'est pas vrai qu il nous faut en fait
croire que 1 et font de la vie des gangs
forêt de contes la de comptes de
réaliser à temps de mettre l'art dans la
vie c'est impossible mais quand tu
restes fait légaux qui est volaille
si moins qu'il ait fait avant goût et à
ce moment là si de là je comprends
pourquoi ton canard ça fait pas mal
quand même
pourquoi parce que je suis baba c'est
bien non c'est juste que tu expliques
des trucs qui pour les gens en l'air
saugrenue inepte et en fait tout ça est
fait avec des vraies raisons
c'est vrai alors il ya un échafaudage
théorique solide c'est pas de la fausse
nouveauté dans la mesure où n'importe
quoi n'importe comment n'importe où
malgré que n'importe quoi n'importe
comment n'importe où peut être une très
belle à une condition c'est quand
l'assument théoriquement faut savoir où
on met ses pieds
et si on devait donner une définition de
toit par exemple tu as dit je suis le
plus grand mauvais peintre tu vois que
c'est bien ça non ben moi j'aime
beaucoup la cuisine qui disait qu'il
voulait être un petit mètre du xxème
siècle raté mais parce que je trouve que
les ratings pour les réhabiliter aussi
c'est vrai que daltoniens ouicher
daltonienne c'est pour ça que tu as pas
fait de la chanson qu'on aime les gens
daltonienne au lendemain du tout gilles
a cogné notre exemple bon ben je te vois
quoi bon mais ça va qu'ils aient droit
d'envoyer des durées daltonienne défaut
daltoniens les demies daltoniens j'dois
et demi d'antenne y voit pas les marrons
les bleus les mâles et mais je suis
important saison et l'histoire du bo ne
compte plus et cette histoire du
beausset soit de nouveau l'histoire
l'accueil est hérité d'un rembrandt et
mathis quand ils sont arrivés c'était
nouveau
oui tremblante l'astuce de la lumière
mathis la suisse des ciseaux chacun son
astuce l'histoire de l'enseigné les mecs
y trouve des idées à chaque fois quoi
toujours alors maintenant diront ça
c'est beau ce sera bon c'est pas vrai
c'est toujours eux étaient des types qui
rompt avec quelque chose à dire qu'ils
ont découvert quelque chose de nous
à dire seulement il faut se rappeler que
tout ça c'est le pouvoir qui aiment se
regarder dans un miroir
c'est lire que signé ton départ on paie
une bonne femme avec un bébé dans les
bras c'est parce que les papilles tout
pour moi si aujourd'hui on peint du coca
cola c'est parce que qu aucun collège de
bois donc j'ai dit toujours que là c'est
exactement ce que le pouvoir veut qui se
peignent son propre reflet et là à ce
moment là on peut commencer à réfléchir
cela et je voudrais que les artistes
deviennent intelligents le lit leçon
série qui réfléchissent à ce qu'il sent
comment ils sont aujourd'hui avec le
bicentenaire en les manipuler l'histoire
de l'albien une mayonnaise c'est bien
des produits qu'on vous fait monter en
d1 il ya quelque chose qui sonne faux
dans le monde là ça sert à quoi là ça je
me suis demandé là je te le dire moi
j'ai pensé un moment donné à une
histoire de bien-être mais j'y crois pas
je voyais ça m'angoisse plus qu'autre
chose à cause de l'âge dans le monde de
la nuit
c'est drôle mais mieux ce serait mieux
mais j'arrive pas abandonner là et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu